Gregg what's our first headline our
first headline is about one of my
favorite NFL players Philip Rivers who
revealed this week his wife Tiffany is
due for their ninth kid everyone's happy
for him and he in a video he credits his
religion and something he calls the
natural planning method for his wife's
fertility let's do it let me just say
that okay like whenever someone's got a
lot of kids I'm the oldest of five
people big Oh your parents Catholic it's
like yeah my dad was but that wasn't why
we had five kids okay it wasn't like oh
we just don't believe in birth control
so you can like be Catholic and still
have a family the smart way and not
overextend yourself and destroy yourself
financially by just cranking out kids
Phillip Rivers didn't worry about money
he's got he's Catholic but he also I
think more than just Catholic he loves
to bone play this video we're gonna play
in its entirety
this is him doing a video promoting the
National Natural planning method and
when I heard it I was like this is
insane I even thought the same thing it
was for us it was a fancy word for no
contraception only I like how it sounds
so scientific the natural planning
method yeah like having unprotected sex
it's yeah it's it's not stupid anything
that's been the method for a couple
thousand years yeah you do it all off
your wife's cycle and what day she's
most fertile one day she's not fertile
so therefore you can together either
really try to have a child or really not
there's been many wives who have
practiced this with their husbands that
attest to the discipline
they sacrifice discipline and sacrifice
imagine talking about your wife in this
way on camera and being happy with it I
feel bad though because Philip River
seems like a genuinely great guy and his
wife loves him but yeah you know the
first like he seems like a good dad a
fantastic husband and a complete and
utter psychopath complete him screaming
on the sidelines and going nuts like
what do you want him to be the
quarterback for your team yes he's a
great quarterback and part of its
because of his insanity but he's like if
he was if he was like a little bit less
of an athlete he'd be the craziest gym
teacher in the world he would not stop
using contraception it's a little it's a
little left to center but it is funny
just to hear him use those words that
like he would be using to like fire up
his offensive line while they're running
some gassers in the middle of July like
discipline sacrifice like let's get some
pain but yeah that's not what you want
to be thinking about he's talking about
the rhythm method he's talking about
things that get people kicked out of
high school all right as I said this is
the sweetening program I checked out the
website I mean it's all about you know
trying to time the calendar so you're
either going for it or you're not it's
this is insane it's like if you love God
then you get yourself a calendar and you
only have sex on the right days not the
devil's days unless you want to have
nine children and then you go ahead yeah
but he just loves it I mean he would do
anything you know so much he wants us
all to do it and it's like Philip Rivers
got married in college just a bone all
he wants to do is be boning when he's
playing football if he's not winning the
game he's just max he's a guy could be
having sex right now with my wife I know
what day it is it's a sex day and I'm
sitting here watching the Giants run up
20 on us he's nuts but it's like no
one's been happier though like he seems
super happy I mean he doesn't know he
doesn't even seem happy
he seems intense he seems intense he
seems like it like a preacher like
trying to preach about Jesus and telling
you you're gonna go to hell if you don't
do this that's not happiness that is
insanity
Bret fires back on the show
right he a regular contributor to the
rosenthal and Jeselnik vanity project
our Chafee departure but I know we
haven't heard from too much this year
until one of my favorite stories of the
year a white supremacist group tricked
Brett Favre into giving him a shout-out
it had to do with this this app called
cameo where you can pay a celebrity to
record a message for you in this group
who calls itself the gdl the goyim
defense League has done this with a few
different celebrities they essentially
paid and tricked Brett Favre into
spreading their propaganda yeah this is
like a thing they like to do where they
like to just yeah they have like little
codes they got who did they soldier boy
I think they got and they got Brett
Favre and the company Cammie was
supposed to you know vet these to make
sure these things don't come through but
but they dropped the ball here yeah Greg
what's the exactly yeah the videos been
taken down yeah but people saw the video
before it was taken down and this is
what he said Brett Favre here with the
shout out to the handsome truth and GDL
boys you guys are patriots in my eyes so
keep waking them up and don't let the
small get you down keep fighting to and
don't ever forget the USS Liberty and
the men and women who died on that day
god bless and take care that's uh you
know I don't think I don't think Brett
I'd loved any of that I'm sure he'd just
read it word for word verbatim so I
don't think I don't think Brett Favre is
to blame at all for this it's a little
embarrassing for him more embarrassing
for cameo well we'll probably why he's
Brett Favre by the way doing this
500 bucks is 500 bucks I guess what are
those he does the copper copper arm
commercials I just feel like for the
level of stature of celebrity and career
that he had he should be he's you're
going a little higher he just have a
little bit of dignity yeah a little more
standards they be crossbows cost a lot
of money
you
[Music]